a firefighter drops off his car to get
service but it's what happened next that
had him calling the eight news now
i-team his car ended up getting stolen
from that dealership so what rights do
you have if your car is getting fixed
and the place loses it the i-team's
david charns with that answer
the great car las vegas firefighter art
nevan really likes tesla everything's
completely pretty much controlled by the
ipad in fact he's already pre-ordered
his next one but it's what happened when
he dropped off his car to get serviced
here at the tesla dealership on sahara
near rainbow that has him not so happy
they called me and he tells me hey i
don't know how to say this but we had an
incident at tesla and someone broke into
our dealership and stole your car
navon's car stolen from the lot i
thought he was joking and
nope sure enough my my car was stolen
the police report obtained by the 8 news
now i-team says navon's car was taken
sometime between the night of december
4th a saturday in the morning of
december 6th a monday according to the
report employees left a bay door open a
man walked in found an unsecured key fob
the one tinavon's car and drove off
according to the report metro didn't
find out about the incident until the
next day tuesday the 7th it blows me
away that they were able to go in take
it out and then drive all the way to
jean
jean as in on the way to california the
thief ditching his tesla on the 15 when
it ran out of juice and now i'm having
to deal with the result of it
so what rights do consumers have when a
dealership or body shop loses your car
the dealership is certainly
liable peter goats is a lawyer with the
legal aid center of southern nevada you
don't expect as a consumer to have your
vehicle taken to a mechanic and it gets
stolen or further damaged goat says it's
up to the dealership to fix any new
problems with the car like cosmetic
repairs from that thief's joyride but he
says in any situation where your car is
getting serviced there is no state law
requiring they stick to a timeline and
there's nothing saying the dealership is
liable for potential decrease in value
that's something that would be very
difficult to prove
because you would have to have some
expert to say that your vehicles would
have been worth
a higher value but for
the
stolen
character of the vehicle nearly two
months after it was stolen navon says he
hasn't gotten his car back do you feel
violated it's like getting broken into
your house have you ever been your house
broken into you it's not the same
experts say the best thing you can do in
these types of situation is try to work
it out with your car insurance we did
reach out to both the dealership here
and tesla corporate several times
specifically asking how they secure
their keys and how they work with
customers in these types of situations
we did not hear back near sahara and
rainbow i'm david charns live local now
david thank you and we checked with
nivan one more time tonight and he says
he still has not gotten his car back he
added there have been additional
stresses with all this since the only
way he can communicate with tesla is
through an app he says his messages have
gone unanswered for days at a time